على وقع المعارك المحتدمه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وادعاء كل من
الطرفين انه في طريق الحسم وان لديه اليد
العليا في الصراع يبقى السؤال في السودان
كيف ستنتهي الاشتباكات بين الجانبين وما
هي السيناريوهات المحتمله لوقف القتال
البرهان واحمد كلاهما متشبث بخيار التصعيد
فجيش السوداني رفض اي نوعا من التفاوض مع
قيادات الدعم السريع كما قرر حلها ولوحها
بمحاكمه قائدها حميدتي في حال القبض عليه
في المقابل اكد حميتي ان لا تراجع عن
مواصله القتال ودع المجتمع الدولي للتحرك
ضد ما وصفها بجرائم جنرال الاسلامي
الراديكالي مراقبون يقولون ان المعارك لن
تنتهي الا بالحسم العسكري بانتصار احد
الطرفين وان سيناريو التفاوض ممكن فقط في
حال تدخلت الواصفات من الدول الصديقه يجلس
الطرفان على طاوله الحوار